we have so much tonight again the
biggest music night was last night and
all your favorite artists made their way
to las vegas for the 64th annual grammy
awards yeah and unlike the oscars the
night wasn't full of many surprises with
the exception of john baptiste who took
home five grammys including the highly
coveted album of the year trophy beating
out albums from justin bieber billy
eilish olivia rodrigo taylor swift and
more and over the weekend john had
another surprise to sharon during an
appearance on cbs sunday morning he
revealed that he secretly got married to
his long-time partner seleka jawad who
currently is battling leukemia for the
second time
you are married we are married we've
been secret married until this moment
when did you get married
we got married the day before i was
admitted to the hospital to undergo my
bone marrow transplant so when did you
get married it was in uh
february
okay this has happened but this isn't
going to interrupt the plan that we had
we have a plan
we're moving towards a plan
and this is just a bump in the road
and
something like getting married can be
an act
of optimism an act of declaration an act
of
we have a future yes
it's an act of defiance
the darkness will try to overtake you
but just turn on the light
focus on the light
oh
you know first of all congratulations to
him last night his speech was absolutely
brilliant and it was emotional his dad
was there and just taking all that in
and then hearing about this um you know
one of people thinking that he got
married just because she had leukemia
that's not the case he was making the
ring for years they've been together for
eight years and this just felt like the
right time and they went into her second
set of dealing with um the cancer with a
lot of happiness knowing that they're
together and it's such a beautiful story
and he's such a you could see such a
kind guy such a kind guy and i think i
had some friends texting me last night
being like who is this john baptiste
like i've never really heard his music
before and that's what i love about the
grammys is even myself i work in
entertainment and there's a few people
that i see on a red carpet that i'm like
who is that and then you kind of
discover them and i mean his voice is
beyond it's incredible and just such a
sweet story we love love yeah we love
love and and and i think the fact that
he even spoke about this secretly gay
mary just brings so much more the fact
that he just didn't never really told
anybody until now we figured this out
and his wife also wrote a book about her
journey the first time dealing with
cancer so kudos to both of them uh
finding that moment together and and you
know just john is living his moment
right now so i'm really really happy for
him